right here I've gotta get up in like
five minutes
[Music]
we
[Music]
[Music]
Iraq has it without JFK Konza stepping
Germany and it's Romania for what with
me ours is that F summer like 10 or 12
10 or 12 hours of malaria and then back
which is literally sitting here like
trying to debate like let's make a
different kind of family
so we'll see won't come up with right
now and you will see it pressures on
down from electric Valley happens now we
have
simply under being honest I'm trying to
buckle you and hit the road
simply I'm just simply I'm just empty ox
being not a diamond tryna [ __ ] me you
only hit the road
there'll be others maybe I'm just 50 I'm
just bein honest I'm puzzles really hit
the road cannot get a handle on my
emotions I want to be
how are the fingers coming doesn't even
stuff though they want to think again to
jump into [ __ ] my giggles - bubble
you a hit allowed bibliothek
50 other fifty armies Bahamas I'm sort
of bubbles you may hit the water I'm in
Romania to harass beautiful city
maybe you'll get some prune village gear
rocket I got a weird sleeping pattern
two hours here two hours they're heading
over the main menu now for the keynote
I'm behind it's just fine this better
hello how are you very good I came from
fresh home my bread no I'm gladly riding
my [ __ ] glad we made it rock off of it
thank you mom thank you take care right
and so here we are it's gorgeous
first of all second of all I'm excited
energy is there I'm trying to find mine
when I sleep like two hours at a time
over 24 hours
it just awkward it's awkward d-roc you
know busy are just simply objects
50 cent of money [ __ ] well enough
segregated in the highlands most lovely
slight Pyrrha this is real life real
life for me I'm driven by gratitude I'm
just thankful that I get to play my game
I love the process much more than the
riches I've never been somebody who
wanted the cars or the shoes or the
house or the plane for me I just wanted
to be the best of the game and so I feel
like I'm a purebred entrepreneur and so
just waking up to play the game to put
on the Jersey to get on the field that's
what drives me I am but I'm getting
closer
building up it's like
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
locus [ __ ] cool thank you so much I'm
very very excited to be here this
afternoon every damn one in China to
meditate estimize what a line is it a
young tiny dare live in heaven standing
on my critic to everything this metaphor
is acting to marry game [ __ ] tornado
sticking it up until therapist when I
spend more time on HR than anything else
I do more than fails more than being
Garry be more than selling more than
anything more than the product services
the majority of my time is spent on HR
this I landed here
I took a two-hour nap right now I woke
up for 30 minutes before I got here it
was all HR this person this this
person's feeling that this person's
mother passed away which is devastating
like what are we going to do like all HR
HR HR HR HR the world is human the
people are the game so actions backing
up the words because there's a lot of
people who are good people and [ __ ]
awesome of what they do thank
[Applause]
[Music]
here's why we do I would probably use
Facebook very aggressively against the
advertising capability of employees of
organizations or against individuals
that you know you're targeting and what
I would do if I were you actually is I
would go into the events business let me
explain what I mean by that based on
what I'm hearing from you I would
probably use social media and digital
advertising and heck above the line
traditional advertising as a gateway
drug to private dinners and many
conferences what I love about b2b
businesses especially when it's big
decisions big dollars small groups of
people is I want to get them in so for
me the wine-tasting or conference that
look like this for all the mayors and
entrepreneurs and business people once
the quarter once a year using one of the
things we've done for very big b2b plays
that are more infrastructure plays like
that is we've used Facebook to create to
be an invitation to a very premium event
got them there and you know after a
little bit of Rosie from Slovenia you
know alcohol is an incredible gateway
drug to a big deal
so you mean use it just just as just as
a way to get in contact with them to get
in touch with them and back to the great
statement that was said here if you're
offering them an exclusive first 25
people that register go to this
wonderful place with this wonderful meal
with this wonderful event or speaker or
performance they just come in droves and
we've been able to very successfully
because of Facebook Ads underpriced
we've been able to get small private
events we're selling 5 10 15
million-dollar apartments on Facebook by
targeting high net worth individuals
inviting them to high end dinners and
then quote and then and then the company
takes over and closes two or three of
them this happen only locally like in
their cities or call them into a
different city like kianga kilometers
away so I would tell you that it depends
on the creative of the evening right if
you get the most famous [ __ ] person
on earth people will go anywhere right
so I think you have to map what are you
offering them right if it's you know if
you're if you're pouring 1982
first-growth Bordeaux they may go a
little further you know I think you've
got to figure out what the value prop is
compared to the distance and make it
worth their while to comments just the
value of change 5149 if you create but
what's really great is you could go big
I like small I like the eighth person
dinner series once every two weeks get
them into your confines bring them value
you know those mayor's those
entrepreneurs they have similar themes
and things they care about bring content
or speaker or performance or information
that's valuable to them holistically not
even even if it's about tax reform has
nothing to do with your stadium building
but you brought them value you're the
host you're there and away you go
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
maybe under being on the gun who's gonna
blow in it alone simply and neatly under
being on the ganja tryna [ __ ] was you a
hit a roll today buddy I'm just simply
I'm just came in thinking few words for
Romania people watching you one life
baby don't [ __ ] wasted hustle
thank you very welcome take care bye so
you know I'm fortunate enough that I get
to do this
a lot a lot of cities a lot of
conferences every year for the last
seven eight years the energy the warmth
the desire you know maybe it's my
emotion of being born in Eastern Europe
kind of coming home ish to that area so
we really have to focus on your
strengths yeah what you said but it is
only one train there is this theory with
the low category like you are good at
one or two or three things I do think
depending on your natural strengths to
the best land everything some people
have one two three four skills so
uncomfortable that my bigger thing is
that I think people waste time and
energy dwelling on what they're not good
at or putting all the renergie and
getting a little bit better that's
something that will never happen so for
me I don't care if it's one two or three
things I just care that it's actually
about things that you're actually good
at not things that you wish you were
good well head of a group or when the
concrete I pull money like Hatcher's
noble on fee I'm kidnapping a foreman of
revolutions buckle to politic and I run
it up like a movement never sever the
most makeup and elusive thought another
corrosive it giving media because people
really care
they never do
[Music]
all fault guys won't be rectified that's
awesome
where you going I'm going to UPenn
amazing amazing
yeah I'll tell you people yeah there's
nothing you're in a learning class
that's going to matter and you guys are
going to good schools it's not going to
matter
I go to Stanford and Harvard immortan I
go although place all the curriculum is
outdated it's outdated I need to the
best schools in the world but your
roommate the people you hang out with
when you go to those kind of schools
they have very interesting families and
relationships it's all relationships all
of it all of it all of it all of it all
on got it yeah
director you're in it right now I think
it's this sure of course you know
[Music]
in a row look I think it comes down to
personal stuff are you asking to drop
out of university are you going to go
are you going to go to Universal samman
I think all the skills including a
Bitcoin isn't that arbitrage that I for
that or the big that plays out I would
tell you the one thing is if you have
the ability to be good at behaving that
way your your abilities they trade real
life is even greater
so before you can always settle
something trading that figure out if you
can trade attention no I get it I get it
but there's a difference between your
skills and trade if you understand of
course you do we did it I understand
that so I would just say like apply a
lot of [ __ ] here a lot of questions good
at before you settle into this makes me
money so many kids that talent I [ __ ]
just settling on the corner crypto or
for actually out realizing they could be
making tens of millions instead of tens
of thousands try sharing your biggest
advantage of time with everything I've
done in my life between all of that new
services all of it twenty forty years of
[ __ ] take it right now you know take
advantage of that
and I have this guy would be a so I can
have accountability so thank you Gary
for this my pleasure
so that's a great question started
interrupt you he asked a great question
I said give your manifesto to the world
he's got the experience he's actually
done it I'm very proud of you for doing
this good hi
so just working on logistics to get to
the VIP dinner but a super successful
good talk
d-roc made a rare appearance on stage
Haidee rock funny thing is when you're
looking behind the camera you don't like
being in front of it I'm going to film
you but answer the question looking good
do you rock good good that was a super
exciting well some days you got to grind
through I'm 203 hours sleep but how
would you agree you did a great job man
I'm very impressed I do a lot of these
like you know I'm now very much looking
forward to Singapore I know it's already
in good shape
no pressure buddy I mean
value 3d engine then the other namely an
sleeve and a scarf W in a row vivianne
skies direction this is the golden era
everything is magical and sunny and I'm
very happy for you d Rocco
[Music]
the lighting it was the golden hour
hello how are you
Rob amaze Wednesday was very very yeah
are you no man can it can I feel that
your entrepreneurship has been painted
in a place where it's just not true
it's very hard it's lonely it's 99%
don't succeed it's a it's been given a
pulse you know position and it's
dangerous being a media player producing
content it's like it's creating the
honey the bees come to you my eye I
didn't realize this about myself until
last last year I was raising 150 million
dollar fund and I stopped and gave back
forty five million dollars that I had
raised already gave it back because I
realized I didn't like asking for money
I don't like selling I don't like
selling I don't like selling I'm telling
I know that's a very weird thing I
figured out why I'm good at it I'm very
good at it because I don't sell you see
me too right I let it come to me so when
I had to go and say do you want to give
me ten million dollars
I'll invested you'll get you know like
if I didn't like the process I didn't
like notice how I said I even felt guilt
or responsibility to pay back my parents
my parents so I was sitting there and
said wait a minute if I fail and I was
already getting uncomfortable with fake
entrepreneurs and getting harder to
invest when I invested when I invested
the only people that were building
startup companies on web 2.0 were really
pure you know they were in it for in it
it was ten years ago
now all the business people are in it
like me so I was already a little
uncomfortable that I was going into a
difficult market to invest him but when
I realized oh my god
if I leave this money I'm going to pay
everybody back it made no sense to do it
I could feel it in my body that if I was
to lose your ten million dollars that I
would have had to for my own feelings
give it back you would feel the right I
couldn't I don't know the reason I think
I'm a nice person is because of the
following I wouldn't know how to act if
I knew I did something bad like the
thought to go somewhere in public and
know I did something wrong to him I
don't have that gear I don't have that
gear
I'm political I'm a Salesman I'm Brander
I've got spiash news I don't have the
ability to do something wrong and make
pretend that I did it
[Music]
no sensative that pregnant right so
that's what I try to tell my change of
friends and say look I love that you
care about your company so much and you
want to help a change so here's my
recommendation have a back-up plan
because then you have the audacity to be
achieved the reason I've done so well is
I won't waver and I lose tons of I said
it today I can have such a bigger
business if I was just if I just
accepted programmatic banner ad buying
if I just accepted that I would do one
hundred million dollars more in revenue
a year we lose pitches constantly
because I will not let them do banner
ads on the web and they then don't pick
up all in right order because because
when you're half pregnant they have
things to poke and prod at you right if
you're being selective they can write
you off because you've wavered in other
areas so then you're not a change agent
it's hard why so people can make it
happen you've got to have the leverage
yeah I need to go somewhere quiet okay
okay come with me or I probably thanks
guys I'll be back
[Music]
get it to work before be Rocky's classic
you know just a classic Romanian lake
business call scene you're pumped right
we may have to go with a classic episode
may have to show that first right yeah I
think we should I were just literally
sitting here like trying to be like this
week a different kind of people
because we need that when it's not you
know pushes on down record valley huh
now we have you so let me let me tell
you a story of something that is
subjective and something that is not
here is something that is subjective the
quality of the content you make
something and you have a client and they
go rubbish or on phenomenal you both say
it's phenomenal you know this you put it
out and it doesn't do anything I've made
videos who you are back home Alexa
distance in a [ __ ] kill and then
nothing happens creative the quality of
the product is subjective until it seems
surreal
it just shows that that's what you're
doing here what I mean I think the
biggest thing I would say one of the
biggest things that happen in my career
was dailyvee it showed people that I was
actually working that hard and there was
no longer debate was I just saying
hustle what was I doing it I wish i sat
one place for nine hours I would love
that time lapse because I just think
it's powerful it means you're just
grinding you're doing your thing they're
doing nine hours of him negotiating
deals is probably the most powerful
video he could put out nine hours of him
in a speakerphone yelling right yelling
with against this wine company and that
shoe company and that sneaker cup like
God knows I'm an influence on the sake
those were he's doing like that's what
he's doing up that Zach Jim and that's
documented
that's a documentary versus a sitcom
where you're trying to do it at a pretty
late core let me go to this carnival or
I'm going to go to the big football
match just to show something creative
that's creating
and I think when I started pushing
documenting it liberated people because
it's hard to create it's hard to be
creative but it's very easy to document
most people just think documenting is
boring but that's kind of weirdly the
punchline I think my biggest failure was
the things that I did not do because I
have so many options so I mean big
failures I can speak about passing on
uber twice right that's four hundred
million dollars in cash that's
life-changing game-changing so that's a
failure but to me I know it's something
that I don't know it's the conference I
didn't speak at that would have made me
meet Elon Musk that would have led to
this I get so many offers that it's the
profit you guys know that show on CNBC
do they show that here on the Internet
it's a big big business show in America
I passed on being the site what to do
yeah Wow I just didn't think I didn't
want to do it I didn't think it was
going to be good you know so so it's all
you know it's all the things that I
didn't do that are my bigger family
[Music]
how are you
a version of no Iligan pilot hey there
guys I'm here with the one the only the
hottest speaker in the world Gary
Vaynerchuk hey guys how are you oh my
god Gary do you know that you inspired
me to do this vlog makes me happy man
yeah man I have done [ __ ] my whole life
I didn't document but yeah I was going
to garage sales I was doing baseball
card shows I worked at the liquor store
everyday every night doing is the only
option if you're sitting and watching
this man right now and you want to be
like him in the same way he wanted to be
like me probably before me you want to
be like Casey and others there's only
one way to do it you've got to do it so
there's no pondering there's no thinking
there's no tomorrow what what about the
over fingers everybody everything's over
too much I think why do you think so few
people win because why don't I people do
[ __ ] that's why my friend like what do I
think about the other thinkers I think
they're the market I think that's 99% of
the world like that's the punchline
thank you Gary you're welcome you're the
best
real pleasure man real pleasure I am
shaking right now you know pleasure
you're welcome I love that it's kind of
cool actually in a frame so frame jokes
yes so yeah I love it
gorgeous thank you so much you guys are
very sweet thank you so much thank you
thank you for all your help at the
airport and everything I appreciate it
thank you
all right bye guys I like 11:30
yeah that's pretty tricky later and so
what what is it now
a lot of things approaching - they
cannot afford to - to change all the
boys feels feels appropriate to be here
in people's house people square in
Bucharest huge huge Center built by the
communist regime I'd be lying if I
didn't say every time I'm in this part
of the world there is some sort of weird
chemical feels towards the epicenter of
where I'm from but just it is just a
gorgeous city these communist buildings
can get a little dull especially when
they tore down all the incredible
architecture originally what there's an
amazing trip an amazing group of people
definitely a city that I want to come
back and visit and one that I recommend
for others and just an enjoyable trip
you rock you liked it fun right nice
little change of pace miss you guys see
you tomorrow
[Music]
thank you brother in one spark for 30
yes okay
[Music]
Frank I'll see sense that you take it
right there by me get up in like five
units like sure let the king
if you're invited worthless
[Music]
[Music]
it